[MUSIC PLAYING]
SANDEEP GUPTA: My
name is Sandeep Gupta.
I'm a product manager in Google.
YANNICK ASSOGBA: And
I'm Yannick Assogba,
and I'm a software engineer
on the TensorFlow.js team.
SANDEEP GUPTA: And we are
here to talk to you today
about machine learning
and JavaScript.
So the video that
you just saw, this
was our very first
AI-inspired Google Doodle.
And it was able to
bring machine learning
to life in a very
fun and creative way
to millions of users.
And what users were
able to do with this
is that you're able to use a
machine learning model directly
running in the browser
that was able to synthesize
a box-style harmony.
And what made this possible
was this library called
TensorFlow.js.
So TensorFlow.js is an
open-source library for machine
learning in JavaScript.
It's part of the TensorFlow
family of products,
and it's built specifically to
make it easier for JavaScript
developers to build
and use machine
learning models within their
JavaScript applications.
You use this library
in one of three ways.
You can use one of the
pre-existing pre-trained models
that we provide, and directly
run them within your JavaScript
applications.
You can use one of the models
that we have packaged for you,
or you can take pretty much any
TensorFlow model that you have
and use a converter and run
it with TensorFlow JavaScript.
You can use a
previously-trained model,
and then retrain it with your
own data to customize it,
and this is often useful
to solve the problem that's
of interest to you.
This is done using a technique
called transfer learning.
And then lastly, it's a
full-feature JavaScript library
that lets you write
and alter models
directly with JavaScript.
And so you can create
a completely new model
from scratch.
Today in this talk, we will
talk a lot about the first
and the third one of these.
For the re-training
examples, there
are a bunch of these on our
website and in the codelabs,
and we encourage you to sort
of take a look after the talk.
The other part is
that JavaScript
is a very versatile
language, and it works
on a variety of platforms.
So you can use TensorFlow.js
on all of these platforms.
We see a ton of use
cases in the browser,
and it has a lot of
advantages because, you know,
browser is super interactive.
You have easy access to sensors,
such as webcam and microphone,
which you can then bring into
your machine learning models.
And also we use
WebGL-based acceleration.
So if you have a
GPU in your system,
you can take advantage
of that and get
really good performance.
TensorFlow.js will also run
server-side using Node.js.
It runs on a variety of mobile
platforms in iOS and Android
using mobile web
platforms, and also it
can run in desktop
applications using Electron.
And we'll see, later in the
talk, more examples of this.
So we launched TensorFlow.js
one year back last March,
and then earlier this year
at our developer summit
we released version 1.0.
And we have been amazed to see
really good adoption and usage
by the community, and some
really good sort of popularity
numbers.
We are really,
really excited to see
more than 100 external
contributors who
are contributing to and
making the library better.
So for those of you who are
in the audience or those
of you listening, thank
you very much from all
of the TensorFlow.js team.
So let's dive a little bit
deeper into the library
and see how it is used.
OK, I'm going to
start with looking
at some pre-trained
models first.
So I want to show you
a few of these today.
So we have packaged a
variety or a collection
of pre-trained models
for use out of the box
to solve some of the most
common types of ML problems
that you might encounter.
These work with images.
So we-- for tasks such
as image classification,
detecting objects, segmenting
objects, and finding boundaries
of objects, recognizing
human gesture and human
pose from image or video data.
We have a few
speech audio models,
which work with speech commands
to recognize spoken words.
We have a couple of text models
for analyzing, understanding,
and classifying text.
All of these models are packaged
with very easy-to-use wrapped
APIs for easy consumption
in JavaScript applications.
You can either NPM install
them, or you can directly
use them from our hosted
scripts with nothing to install.
So let's take a look
at two examples.
The first model I want to show
you is an image-based model.
It's called BodyPix.
So this is the model that
lets you take image data,
and it finds whether there is
a person in that image or not.
And if there is a person,
it will segment out
the boundary of that person.
So it will label each
pixel as whether it
belongs to the person or not.
And you can also do
body part segmentation.
So it can further divide up the
pixels that belong to a person
into one of 24 body parts.
So let's take a look at
what the code looks like
and how you would use
a model like this.
So you start by
loading the library
and by loading the
model using the script
tag from our hosted scripts.
You choose an image file.
You can load it from disk or you
could point to a webcam element
to load it from the webcam.
And once you have
an image, then you
create an instance
of the BodyPix model,
and you call its person
segmentation method
on the image that
you have chosen.
Because this runs
asynchronously,
you wait for the
result and we do that
by using the wait keyword.
So once you get back
the segmentation result,
it returns an object,
and this object
has the width and the
height of the image,
and also a binary array of zeros
and ones, with the pixels where
the person is found are
labeled, and you see that
in that image on the right.
You could also use the body
parts segmentation method
instead of the
person segmentation
method, in which case you
would get the sub-body part
classification.
The model is packaged with
a set of utility functions
for rendering, and here
you see the example
of the drawPixelatedMask()
function,
which produces this
image on the right.
OK, so this is how you would use
one of these image-based models
directly in your
web application.
The second model I want to show
you is a speech commands model.
So this is an audio
model that will look for,
that will listen
to microphone data,
and try to recognize
some spoken words.
So you can use this to build
voice controls and interfaces
or to recognize
words for translation
and other types of applications.
So let me quickly switch
to the demo laptop.
So we have a small glitch
application written,
which uses the speech
commands model,
and we are using a version
of a pre-trained model, which
is trained on a vocabulary of
just four simple words-- up,
down, left and right.
So when I click start and
I can speak these words,
this application will
display a matching emoji.
So let's try it out.
Left.
Up.
Down.
OK.
Right.
Left.
Up.
There we go.
We can go back to the screen.
This actually points to what
you would frequently encounter
with machine learning models.
There are a lot of other factors
that you have to account for--
things like background
noise, and just training data
representing adequately
the type of data that it
will encounter in real life.
So let's again take a look at
what the code would look like.
Again, you use the script
tag similar to before
to load the model and
to load our library.
And now, we create an instance
of the speech commands model
and we initialize it or we use
a version of the speech commands
model that's trained for
the specific vocabulary
of interest.
So in this case, it's
this directional four-word
vocabulary.
We have packaged this model with
a couple of other vocabularies
that you can use, and also
you can extend this model
to your own vocabulary
using transfer learning.
And we have a codelab
which shows how to do that.
So once you have
initiated the model,
then we call its
listen method, which
starts listening to
the microphone data.
And then once it
recognizes these words,
then it returns a set of
probabilities for the matching
score for each of
the spoken words
in its set of labeled classes.
And then once you've figured
out what the spoken word is,
then you can use that to
display emojis, for example,
in that particular example.
OK, so I'm going to
turn it over to Yannick,
who will show you how to do
training using this library.
YANNICK ASSOGBA: Thanks Sandeep.
Hello.
So, Sandeep showed you
one of the simplest ways
to get started with machine
learning with TensorFlow.js,
and that's to take one of
our pre-trained models,
incorporate it into your app.
And, if you noticed,
you won't even
have to think about
tensors, but there
are situations where there
won't be a model that works out
of the box for your
use case, and that's
where training comes in.
So TensorFlow.js has a full
API to support training custom
models right in JavaScript.
So last year here
at I/O, we showed
a demo of training a game
controller using webcam input--
in this example, your face--
to control this Pac-Man game.
And this year, we're going
to look a bit more closely
at the training
process, focusing
on training in Node.js,
and what it looks
like to bring your own data.
Now some of the advantages
of training in Node.js
include generally increased
access to memory and storage,
increased performance in certain
situations, and importantly,
being able to browse
the internet while you
wait for your model to train.
In the browser, when
you're training a model,
you have to keep
the tab focused.
Else, many browsers will
throttle performance
on that tab.
So it's quite handy that you're
able to do something else.
All right, so let's train
a custom text classifier,
and there's really
two main things
I'd like you to take
away from this exercise.
The first is
generally how to work
with text in TensorFlow.js,
and the other
is a general principle of using
an existing building block
to bootstrap your
machine learning project.
This is referred to
as transfer learning,
and it's really helpful
when you're getting
started with machine learning.
And we'll see more about that
in the example, but to step back
a bit, what can you do
with a text classifier?
So there are classical examples,
such as sentiment analysis,
or spam detection,
but you can also
do things like log
scrubbing, where
you may look through
your logs for maybe
personal or private information
that you don't want to keep,
and obfuscate it or remove
it before you store it.
But you can also do things
like analyze product reviews
or do document clustering.
But today, we're going to build
a component for a chatbot,
and in particular,
we're going to look
at classifying user intents.
So, for example,
given the sentence,
"Will it rain in the
next 30 minutes?"
we want the model to detect
that that's a GetWeather
intent, or something like
"Play the latest Bach album,"
should be a PlayMusic intent.
So any machine learning project
needs data to learn from,
and today the data we're
going to use come from
comes from the Snips
AI NLU benchmark,
and it's an open-source dataset
that's available on GitHub.
And for our first
task, we're basically
going to start
with a spreadsheet.
As you can see, it has the
query sentences on one side,
and the intents on the other.
However, one thing we need
to do is convert this text
into numbers so that we can
feed it into our neural network
because neural networks
don't really understand text
natively, and that is where
the Universal Sentence
Encoder comes in.
It's a deep neural
network created by Google
that I like to think
of as NLP in a box.
It takes sentences
and turns them
into lists of numbers
that encode the meaning
and syntax of those
sentences, and we'll
take a look at an example.
So let's think of
this example, "What
is the weather in
Cambridge, Massachusetts?"
The Universal Sentence Encoder
will take that sentence
and turn it into an
array of 512 numbers,
and it will always be
512 numbers regardless
of the length of the
sentence, which is actually
quite nice because it gives
us a regular sort of structure
to work with.
And this is what the code looks
like to create those numbers.
So, similar to what
Sandeep showed earlier,
we load our pre-trained model,
the Universal Sentence Encoder.
We wait for its waits
to finish loading,
and then we call this
model.embed() with
the sentences that
we want to pass in.
And this process of turning
these sentences into numbers
is often referred
to as embedding
in machine learning
terminology, and you'll kind of
hear that term a bit.
So just a bit of
what that looks like.
Wait for the result, and
that's our set of 512 numbers.
OK.
Next is the intent.
So we also have to convert
these into numbers.
So since these are
categories and we
have a small number
of them, we can
use a scheme called
oneHot encoding
to turn the label into a
small array that has a 1
in the position
corresponding to that label.
So in this example, we
have our GetWeather intent,
and notice the first
element of the array is a 1
and the rest are zeros.
In the corner, you
will see the other two
intents we're using in
this demo, the Play Music
one and the AddToPlayList,
and there's always
just a single one in
the array representing
which category this represents.
And here is the code to do
that, and it is basically
an index look-up into a list.
So we call the method
tf.oneHot, given
the index of the label
we want to encode
as well as the total number
of categories we have.
So here, GetWeather and
three, and then it's
going to return that
compact array that
is our numerical
representation of the label.
All right.
So now we have our inputs,
or often as referred to
in machine learning, our xs,
and our targets, which are also
referred to as ys often.
And now our goal is to take
the 512 numbers representing
the input and predict
that smaller array that's
1, 0, 0 that represents
that particular intent,
and we're going to train
a model to do that.
So let's code up a model.
So this is the entire
code for the model.
It's not too much code,
but it does a lot of work,
and as you spend
time with this, it
becomes more and more familiar.
At the top, we see our
EMBEDDING_DIMS, 512,
and NUM_CLASSES that represent
the size of the input
and the output of the
model, respectively.
So 512 numbers coming in,
three numbers going out.
The part that's highlighted is
the entire model definition,
and I won't dwell
on this too long,
but this is a common
building block
you'll see in neural
networks, and it's
known as a dense network.
So we start with a
sequential model,
and this network
just has one layer,
and it's the one dense
layer, and its job
is to convert 512
numbers to three numbers.
That's its entire job.
The deep learning
part will have been
take care of by the
Universal Sentence Encoder.
Finally, we compile the model
to get it ready for training,
and here we pick
an optimizer, which
is an algorithm that's
going to drive the wait
updates during the
training process,
as well as a loss function to
tell us how well we're doing.
And here, we're picking
one that's commonly
used for classification tasks.
So onto the training loop.
So model.fit() is the function
that actually runs the whole
training process, and here
we're calling it with a few
parameters. xs are
our input sentences.
ys are those targets
from our training set,
and then two extra parameters.
epochs is a fancy word that
refers to the
number of times you
go through the data set
before you're done training,
and you can set that kind
of to whatever you want.
validationSplit is a
fraction between 0 and 1,
and it indicates a
portion of the data
that we're going to set
aside and not train with,
but we can use it to
see how well we're
doing at making predictions.
So before we look
at the demo itself,
let's take a quick look
at what the code to deploy
that trained model would
look like in the browser,
and let's just take
a quick sample.
So we'd first load the models
in the metadata, but for now
I just want you to focus on
the three lines in the middle.
So the basic process is
that we take the input query
from the user.
We're going to use the Universal
Sentence Encoder to embed it
into that numerical
representation.
Then we're going to call our
model, with model.predict(),
to get our final prediction.
We're going to call the
.array() to get the values out,
and we're going to use
that to drive our UI.
And in this case, our UI
is going to look something
like this, and it's about
150 lines of JavaScript,
and about 100 lines of CSS.
So it's not terribly large.
So let's get our hands into it.
So if you just switch to
the demo laptop, please.
All right.
So we're just going to sort of
take a quick tour of the code.
It's all available on GitHub.
So here is that spreadsheet
that we started with--
our queries and our intents.
And I've done a bunch of the
pre-processing beforehand,
so that we don't have to wait
for that [INAUDIBLE] complete.
So the first step was
converting it to tensors,
and it's just those long
lists of 512 numbers.
JSON isn't the most efficient
format to store this,
but it's quite readable.
So you can actually just
look at what a tensor is.
It's just a long
list of numbers.
We also have some
metadata for our model.
So these are the three classes
that we're going to train,
and we have about
6,000 sentences
that we're going to learn from.
Our model itself looks
pretty much like what
we saw in the slides.
There's no surprises there.
And finally, our script that's
going to run the training.
Its main job-- it takes
a bunch of options,
but its main job is to load
the data and train the model.
So it's going to do that with
model.fit() as we saw earlier.
We're going to wait for
that to be complete,
and then we're going to
save that model to disk.
So that's going to save a
JSON file and a binary file.
The JSON file contains the sort
of structure of the network.
The binary file contains the
weights in an efficient format.
Both of those are
loadable in the browser,
and that's our basic process.
So let's see what that
kind of looks like.
So here I'm going to run
the training script for this
while I'll say
yarn train-intent.
It's going to load
up, load our script,
and use TensorFlow on the CPU
and we're off to the races.
So each one of these lines
that it prints is an epoch,
and that's a trip
through the entire data
set of about 6,000
sentences, and you
notice it goes pretty quickly.
It typically finishes in
about 20 seconds, and boom--
19.90 today.
And we've trained a model.
It's done.
We can now load that in
the browser and use that
to make predictions.
You can look at the
file that's produced.
It's a really small model file.
So I'm going to start this demo
app, which is here in our app
folder, and it's just like a
client-side JavaScript app,
and this is really where all
the machine learning happens,
where we make our predictions.
So this is going to copy the
model that we just trained over
into the folder for
the client-side app
and launch it in dev mode.
I'm actually going to
lift this a bit higher,
and now we can try
and make predictions.
So we can ask it like, what
is the weather in Cambridge?
Sweet, and it responds with
a nice cloud for like it
has detected a weather query.
Or we can say, play
the latest Bach album.
And it's correctly classified
that as a PlayMusic one.
Or even things like but those
sick beats on my running list--
not that I run
terribly often, but we
get the right response
back of AddToPlaylist,
but what happens when you
give it something surprising?
Like, get me a pizza.
Well, it's just going to
throw its hands up and shrug,
and that's actually
quite useful.
You generally don't
want your model
to do things when it's not
the right thing that it's
been trained to do.
And how we've set this up
is that we set a threshold
for confidence in
classification,
and so it should be
pretty confident in one
of these classes before
it takes that action,
and that's very useful to
think of when you're building
a machine-learning-driven app.
It's sometimes good to say, I
don't know or not [INAUDIBLE]..
So, sweet.
That's our classifier.
Let's head back to
the slides for a bit.
All right.
So we built our
custom classifier.
Yay.
And in many instances, that
might be all that you need.
It may be the final
step of your pipeline,
or once you have
the specific intent,
you can apply some
handwritten rules
to extract information and do
the rest of your processing.
However, we can train
models to do more than just
whole sentence classification.
So, given our
original query, "What
is the weather in
Cambridge, Massachusetts?"
we may want to know, what's
the location-related aspect
of this sentence,
and that's what
we're going to look at next.
So we can reformulate our
problem a bit to this.
So, given a sentence,
we want to tag each word
in the sentence with a tag.
Like TOK for generic
token or LOC for location.
We could have other tag
types, but for now we're
just going to focus on these
two and the weather queries.
Like before, we need to
convert our text into numbers,
and like before, we're going
to use the Universal Sentence
Encoder to do that.
We're just going to give
it one word at a time.
So now each word becomes
an array of 512 numbers,
and in addition we're going
to add these special tokens
at the end of our sentences.
And that's the __PAD tokens.
These will have two purposes.
They'll let us know when
the end of a sentence is,
but more importantly, we're
going to add enough of them
so that all of our sentences
are effectively the same length.
And this will be useful
for us because it gives us
a nice rectangular matrix that
we can use during training,
and that's just way
more efficient to train.
So this is roughly what
our input will look like.
They'll be sort of enough
pad tokens to make everything
a given length.
What about our targets?
So now we want to predict
something for each word,
and we're going to use
oneHot encoding again.
Conveniently, we have three
categories like before.
So we have our TOK category,
our LOC for location,
and the special
pad category that
will tell us when we've reached
the end of the sentence.
And we see the oneHot encoding
scheme just like before.
So once you've done that for
our inputs and our outputs,
we now have them
represented as sequences.
So now each sentence
is a sequence
of those arrays of numbers, and
we need an appropriate model
to handle them.
So you can use a dense
network like before,
though I'd advise maybe
adding some capacity to that,
but today we're going to look
at a special kind of network,
known as a recurrent
neural network,
and in particular a
special kind of layer
known as an LSTM that is geared
towards handling sequences.
So let's take a look at that.
So here is our new
model function.
First, I want you to notice
that the start and end of it
is pretty similar to
what we saw before.
EMBEDDING_DIMS is still 512,
and the number of classes
is still three.
We still start with a sequential
model, and the end of it
is pretty similar.
We're going to compile it
with the same optimizer
and the same loss function.
So really, the meat of
it is in the middle.
So instead of starting
with a dense layer,
we're going to
use an LSTM layer,
and this is a special
kind of layer that--
it's designed to learn
across sequences.
And here, think of each
sentence as a sequence.
So we're going to configure it,
set a maximum sequence length,
and then after that we're going
to do one more special thing.
We're going to
take the LSTM layer
and wrap it in a
bi-directional layer
to give us a
bi-directional LSTM.
And this is useful because
it allows the model
to learn context
in both directions.
So you can think of it as
reading the sentence left
to right and then right to left,
and trying to learn from that.
Finally, we end
with a dense layer,
and this is very common
in classification problems
to end with a dense
layer that has
your number of output
classes, the NUM_CLASSES
that you see in the slide.
But because of the LSTM
stuff we did previously,
we do have to wrap it in this
time-distributed layer that's
going to unroll some
of the sequence stuff
that happened earlier.
So that's our entire
model definition again.
Let's get our hands
into it again.
Let's see what that looks like.
So I'm going to go back
to the demo machine suite.
Let me close that
and head to the code.
Again, I've
pre-prepared the data.
So we can see what
that looks like.
Here's our input data, and it's
just the sentences broken up
into words with a tag for each
word, and somewhere in there
there's some LOC ones.
So that's our input.
Another thing I've done is I've
pre-embedded all of the words,
and just written them to a file.
So we can just look that up
instead of calling Universal
Sentence Encoder each time.
So with that
pre-processing done,
we can look at our
model definition,
and-- sorry this is
the tagger model--
and if you look
at this on GitHub,
you'll see that it's a little
more involved than what's
in the slide, and that's
because the example we've put up
allows you to train three
different kinds of models.
You can train a one-directional
LSTM, the bi-directional LSTM
we were talking about
today, or a dense network.
And that's just to let
you compare and see
how they behave,
but other than that,
it's pretty much the same.
Our training script
is very similar.
The data is a bit bigger.
So there's a little bit
more data management.
So we call
fitDataset() this time,
and then we save that to
disk just like before.
So that's the outline of our
process, and we can run that.
So I'm just going to
yarn train-tagger,
and we'll see what
that looks like.
So we'll start it, and all
of this training, by the way,
is just using CPU.
So you don't necessarily need
a GPU to do any training,
but it does speed things up.
So we've started
training, and probably
the first thing you've
noticed is that it's
a lot slower than before.
The data is much
bigger this time.
Each word is 512 numbers, and
the model is more complex.
So it will take
more time to train,
and I'd say on average
it takes somewhere
between 10 and 20
minutes depending
on what options you pick.
So we're not going to
wait for the whole thing.
To speed up the presentation,
I did train a model last night.
So we're just going
to use that, and look
at a demo app that's designed
to sort of show you the process.
So I'm just going to start
that, yarn tagger-app.
So we copy our model over it
just like before and start up
our front-end
application, and this
is a demo app just
designed to give you
a sense of what is the pipeline
that inputs are going through.
So we can now enter
a query like "What is
the weather in Cambridge, MA?"
So the first line is our input
sentence that's been tokenized.
The sort of grid thing
is a representation
of those 512 numbers from the
Universal Sentence Encoder,
and then below that is our
top category that comes out.
And you can see that Cambridge,
Massachusetts is nicely
classified as being
location-related.
One nice thing about
these models, you can try
is somewhat more
complex ones like "What
is the weather in white
river junction Vermont?"
and that's a place I
have actually been to,
and it does get it correct.
We have this longer
location-related sequence,
and it's correctly tagged the
tokens as belonging to that.
You'll notice the confidence
on the VT is a little lower.
If we use the more
traditional capitalization--
so, "What is the weather in
white river junction VT?"
you'll notice that the
classification score for VT,
the abbreviation for
Vermont, goes way up,
but because we've used
a bi-directional LSTM,
you'll also notice that
the words before that,
their confidence scores
go up because its reading
the context in both directions.
So that can be super handy.
Another thing that's
important to realize
is that it's not just
memorizing place names.
So if you try just typing
in "white river junction,"
it's not going to detect that as
location, or even "white river
junction vt," and
that's because it's
learned to find
these in the context
of these
weather-related queries.
That's the training data.
So it's not just
gone and memorized
a bunch of location
names, for example.
So it's important
to keep in mind.
Like, it's really based on
what you gave it to train.
All right, and we can
switch back to these slides.
Sweet, that worked.
So, yay.
We trained an intent
classifier and a model
that can extract information
from that identified intent.
Sweet.
So is it time to ship
this into production?
I would caution against this.
So you really should
take care to first test
that your model is robust
to different situations,
and that it will match
your user's expectations.
Machine learning models
are probabilistic
and behave differently based
on often subtle differences
in the training data used.
So it's super important to
have a good test set, including
some tricky cases,
and just validate
that with your
users to make sure
it matches those expectations.
And Google has a number of great
resources online on this topic,
and I also recommend
checking out
the designing
human-centered AI products
talk by some of our
colleagues in Google Pair
later this afternoon at I/O.
So now you've seen a bit
of what the workflow looks
like to train a model.
You can check out the
full code on GitHub.
I've included a short
link to it here,
and it's part of our larger
repository of examples.
And next, I'm going
to hand it back
to Sandeep to talk
about different ways
that TensorFlow.js
has been used.
Thanks.
SANDEEP GUPTA:
Thank you, Yannick.
[APPLAUSE]
So we saw how the library can
be used for using and training
machine learning models.
I want to just
take a few minutes
and quickly show you a variety
of applications of what people
are doing with TensorFlow.js.
We saw earlier that it runs on
a bunch of different platforms.
So these examples will
sort of span many of these.
Creatability, this
is a project that's
being developed by the
Creative Labs team in Google,
and this consists of
a set of experiments
where they're
exploring how to use
AI and ML to make these
creative tools more accessible.
These run machine learning
models in the browser,
and in this particular
case you see
a person controlling a keyboard
with head gestures and head
motion.
They have some
really cool examples,
and I encourage you to check out
the experiment sandbox, which
is showing many of these
all on the website.
Uber uses machine learning
in a very significant way
for a wide variety of problems
at a very large scale,
and Manifold is a
browser-based application
that Uber uses to visualize and
debug their machine learning
models and data pipelines.
So this application
runs in the browser,
and they're using
TensorFlow.js for a lot
of numerical computations
that they want to use here.
So, for example, distance
calculations and visualization,
as well as clustering
of data, et cetera.
They were able to find
that, because of the WebGL
acceleration, they
could accelerate
these computations
more than 100x
compared to just natively
using JavaScript.
AirBnB has an
interesting use case
where their Trust team,
when a user is trying
to upload a profile picture to
the AirBnB website, sometimes
people accidentally
use a driver's license
picture or a passport
picture, which
may end up containing personal,
sensitive information.
So AirBnB runs a
machine learning model
directly on your client-side
in the browser or on device
so that if you were to
choose a picture which
may have some
sensitive information,
it will alert you before
you upload that picture
and prevent you from doing that.
On the server-side, Clinic.js
is a really nice example
of an application that
NearForm has built.
This is a Node.js-based
application,
which is used for profiling
node jobs or node processes.
And they're using TensorFlow.js
to look for anomalies or spikes
in CPU usage or
memory consumption
of these node applications.
So it's a really nice example
of server-side application
of TensorFlow.js.
In the desktop, TensorFlow.js
can be used with Electron,
and Magenta Studio
is a set of plugins
that has packaged a collection
of machine learning models
for music generation
that used TensorFlow.js
for some very fun and
creative music applications.
I think Magenta has a talk
later today that you might
want to check out, And they also
have some demos in the sandbox.
We have the Ableton Live
plug-in for this in our sandbox
that you can see.
TensorFlow.js also runs on
mobile platforms on mobile web
both on iOS and
Android, and recently we
have been working
on adding support
for the WeChat application.
So WeChat is a very popular
social media platform
and messaging application,
and it has a mini program
environment, which
lets developers
build these small JavaScript
applications called
mini programs and easily
deploy and share them.
So let's take a quick
look at a prototype
of what this could look like.
So in this video,
what you will see
is a Pac-Man game that's
shared as a WeChat mini-app,
and it will let the user control
this game using head motion
from the phone's camera.
So you see the
WeChat application
being launched here, and
then one of my friends
has shared this mini
program via a link.
And I just click on it
and I launch this game,
and now this game is
a little JavaScript
program that's running within
the WeChat environment.
After I do a very
quick calibration step
by looking straight
up at the phone,
I'm ready to play this game.
And so this Pac-Man
game is loaded,
and you will see in a
moment, my head motion
is driving that little
Pac-Man character.
So a really fun
way of interacting
with device, and
the nice thing is
that you can do a variety of
things using webcams, using
text, using speech, and have a
very convenient way of sharing
these applications without
having to install anything.
So we saw a bunch of examples.
I just want to quickly show
you that the community has
been building some really
interesting applications
and use cases beyond
all the examples
that I've shown you so far.
And for those of
you in the audience
who have been using
TensorFlow.js, a big thank you.
We have a collection
of these examples
that you can check out on
our gallery page, which
are extending
TensorFlow.js and using it
for things like
reinforcement learning
for that self-driving car
example or generative models
and a variety of other
interesting applications.
We also have a
bunch of developers
who are building add-on
libraries as extensions
on top of
TensorFlow.js, and these
are extending TensorFlow.js
in very useful ways
for libraries that
let you track hand
gestures or facial movement
and facial gestures
or also do more things
like hyperparameter
tuning of machine learning
models, et cetera.
So there are a bunch of these
resources also available
on our website.
So in closing, I want to just
point out a couple of resources
to help you get started.
There is this new textbook
that is coming out.
It's called Deep
Learning With JavaScript,
and it's written
by our colleagues
on the TensorFlow.js team.
It's an excellent resource for
learning about deep learning
and machine learning,
and all examples
are written in JavaScript
using TensorFlow.js.
For our audience here
and people listening ,
we have a really nice sort of
an offer of a discount code.
So that might find that useful.
TensorFlow recently also
launched a new Coursera course
for deep-learning AI
to introduce TensorFlow
and machine learning.
And as part of this
course, we will
have a module on
TensorFlow.js, which we'll be
launching in a couple of weeks.
I just want to point out
a few more useful links
on our website for our
models repo, for our gallery.
And then also we have an
office hours session right here
in Google I I/O tomorrow.
You can come by and
ask your questions
and meet the TensorFlow.js team.
You can check out
many more demos
at our demonstration
in the AI/ML sandbox,
and also there are a
few hands-on codelabs
that you can try interactively
in the codelabs area.
So thank you so much for
coming out here today,
and have a great
rest of the I/O.